[Music]
but welcome back to this special edition
of Hannity the liberal mainstream media
is once again Kok colluding with the
left according to a report from the
Washington free beacon quote wopo
reporter goes rogue gives strategy
briefing to secret dem donor conference
the article continues quote Washington
Post reporter Janelle Ross gave a
presentation at a secretive california
gathering where Democratic politicians
liberal activists and their biggest
donors flooded the future of the
progressive movement without notifying
her superiors that she would be
attending according to a post spokesman
the Washington free beacon claims to
have obtained a copy of the conference
agenda the lists of events and featured
guests and according to the agenda
speaking right before Janelle Ross was
none other than leftist billionaire
George Soros we reached out to the
Washington Post for additional comment
and we were told they have nothing more
to share shame all right joining me now
is reaction is the national spokesman
for core conservative commentator Niger
anis founder an executive director of
Turning Point USA at charlie kirk and
from fox news radio todd starnes thank
you all so much for being here with me
tonight so the mainstream media often
fails to cover Democratic scandals do
you think that this report Todd proves
that it is more purposeful than just a
simple kind of ignorant of the scandal
and not really aware of it oh absolutely
as a matter of fact Kimberly this is an
example of not just fake news but
propaganda news where you actually have
a reporter from the Washington Post
going into the secret meeting and
gathering all this information quite
frankly it is a direct violation of the
Society of Professional Journalists code
of ethics Wow
that code of ethics says and I want to
read this here avoid conflicts of
interest real or perceived and avoid
political and other outside activities
that may compromise your integrity well
it's very clear this is exactly what
this Washington Post reporter has done
yet not sure this is quite disturbing
when you hear this report I mean what
were your initial thoughts you know when
you found this out I was not surprised I
mean George Soros is our very own living
doctor evil if he will call from the
comedy films but it's actually deadly
seriously
he's not only the foundation if you will
of every left-wing group and supporter
of every left-wing politician from
Camilla Harris to former President Obama
but he also has an international network
of NGOs that he funds to under sometimes
openly undermine governments and counter
u.s. foreign policy one of the scandals
that I hope that the media really
exposes and investigates
is is something that six US senators
have asked Tillerson to look into which
is how our government is actually
funding NGOs that are tied to George
Soros they're actually contradicting
u.s. foreign policy in places as
far-flung as Macedonia to Zimbabwe
that's the real scandal the fact that
the Washington Post is in bed with these
folk makes me a little concern but I
have to say I'm not really all that
surprised yeah Charlie you surprised I'm
not but it's important to note George
Soros is a big problem but just right
behind him you might have missed the
news with all the black friday shopping
but there's a new richest man he's worth
a hundred billion dollars Jeff Bezos who
conveniently owns the Washington Post
yes in fact he acquired it last year and
he went through a huge purge of anyone
that believed in freedom and hired a
bunch of very left-wing journalists and
reporters and in fact right after Donald
Trump's surprise victory he hired
personally over 50 new journalists and
reporters that went all over Washington
to try to find evidence of Russia
collusion so on and so forth so no this
is of no surprise the Washington Post
which is one of the most well read
newspapers in the country has now become
a political arm of the leftist causes
and you see they're invited on the front
and center stage of the secret meeting
with George Soros but it's important to
remember Jeff Bezos is just right there
with George Soros through the Washington
Post doing this exact same sort of thing
you know he's absolutely right Charlie's
absolutely right taught because he has
become increasingly more you know
dangerous in terms of his level his
reach
certainly his financial ability to
influence and corrupt American
journalism oh absolutely and again
consider what happened here you had a
reporter a reporter who was assigned to
cover president Trump inside the secret
meeting strategy
with these progressives and with these
leftist and The Washington Post they
tell us well we didn't know anything
about it it's it's news to us instead of
being horrified and embarrassed at the
fact that one of their reporters was
demonstrating a clear bias by attending
that meeting yeah and then seemingly no
repercussions whatsoever total blind
ignorance looking the other way Naja to
this situation instead of actually you
know engaging in journalistic ethics and
and following this through and doing an
investigation and then providing some
kind of accountability can you imagine
what would have happened if some Fox
News reporter or some Wall Street
Journal reporter had ties to the Koch
brothers I mean this would be on the top
of 60 minutes this be the top page of
the New York Times the silence on the
left is deafening with this conspiracy
on the left and look there's one thing
that I'm hoping on the next three to
hopefully seven years of president
Trump's administration that he cleans
out the cobwebs of this international
network and and you're right I'm your
other guest all right it's not just
George Soros it's the Cabal of left-wing
folk like Bezos and other billionaires
that we don't hear from that are behind
this international effort to often
undermine and contradict actually stated
u.s. foreign policy and cause domestic
mischief yeah well far-reaching
implications and unbelievably you know
inappropriate the levels of impropriety
know no bounds we Charlie what do you do
about this in terms of like trying to
not just saying hopefully the Trump
administration is going to do something
when do you have some thoughts about
what should be some kind of constructive
framework or plan to try to investigate
this and bring about some accountability
and ethics well there should be some
accountability ethics and it should
start with the Attorney General should
open investigation into the open
societies foundation which is George
Soros is nonprofit which by the way you
just transferred 15 billion dollars into
they have to give away 5% a year and
think about how much money that is but
there's there's good evidence to show
that George Soros has been instrumental
in funding grassroots left-wing groups
such as black lives matter in Antigua
which are now being investigated by the
FBI so you have to follow the money you
have to see is he actually funding these
groups and where they
their source of training and their
financial backing and so what can be
done we need to get the Attorney General
involved to see if there's any mischief
involved in a lot of these domestic
terror groups such as an Tifa but even
more than that we have to expose how the
left have become funded by these scented
billionaires now Jeff Bezos worth a
hundred billion dollars to corrupt our
democracy and to change the trajectory
of this country you know really if my
targets have so such a serious situation
because the implications are so
far-reaching mean you can think back
just to the campaign and the paid
protesters and what was going on they're
really trying to rifle
you know democracy and the election
process and now having the tentacles in
so far is you know very widely read and
mainstream so to speak in terms of
widely available newspapers that can
really impact not just you know American
journalism the truth the facts that get
out there but as we've also discussed
implications of foreign and domestic
policy what what we have seen here is
clear evidence of collusion and it's not
just the Washington Post or remember
back in the campaign when you had CNN
asking the DNC to go over to bake
questions when you had Donna Brazile
turning over those questions to Hillary
Clinton's campaign again this is a very
serious issue and it's important for for
all of the viewers to understand they
need to be news consumers as well they
need to be good stewards of where they
get their news and it's important for
all of us to understand what's really
going on and read with a discerning and
critical eye child to make sure you know
that they're actually getting the truth
you should read from multiple sources
not just one especially and I think that
you said I'll you guys you know follow
the money look to see who is behind it
who is funding this and who is trying to
fill your mind that's exactly right and
the left tries to say that you know
conservatives are the party the rich
will eight out of the 10 wealthiest
counties in America voted for Hillary
Clinton and now you have the world's
richest man and the fourth richest man
in the country funding left-wing causes
trying to disrupt democracy here in this
country and so the left has really been
funded by these people that want to
create a one-world government they do
not want to see America continue its
international dominance and they want to
destabilize capital capitalism as we
know it
this is very very dangerous these are
people that do not share our values and
now that they have unlimited amounts of
money they want unlimited
amounts of power which exactly we know
at the left wants and what viewers have
to do is continue continue to pursue
good news channels such as Fox and read
The Wall Street Journal and stay away
from a lot of these new sources that are
being funded by people that do not share
our values or want to see America
succeed you know charlie brings up a
great point Nigel is just the the
influence and the intention to corrupt
an American you know democracy and
basically mind-control people by putting
forward this propaganda and pretending
parlaying it as journalism following
ethical standards that's the real
problem here that they've been able to
take it this far it's a real crisis and
it's a it's a generational crisis
because the biggest impact of this
propaganda that you speak of is on
college campuses and in our elite
university institutions all across the
country so you have generations being
poisoned and you know we've got an
opportunity with this president in
office
I applaud I think it was Todd who said
that the Attorney General really needs
to investigate this and I hope that
Tillerson will take that letter from six
United States senators that USAID needs
to stop funding these George Soros
related and far left-wing groups that
are oftentimes violent and kind of like
a foreign version of an tyfa that we
spoke of earlier this has got to be
world up now we've got the opportunity
we ought to break this Network up as
quickly as we possibly can okay Todd
quick final thought well look instead of
covering these big issues you have
people like CNN's April Ryan who's out
there suggesting Sarah Sanders faked
baking a pecan pie for Thanksgiving for
goodness sakes this is what we're
dealing can't even make the stuff you
make it up you can't bake Goodison I
don't fake baking pies I'll just get
them in like for the experts all right
thank you guys so much for being with us
today